[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing the history
and family tree of the black family you
might not know this but sirius black was
more than just a powerful wizard who
escaped the dungeons of azkaban
by birthright he was a member of one of
the most powerful wizarding families in
all of britain in fact the black family
line can be traced back through the
centuries and was celebrated as one of
the proudest pureblood families in the
world
and by the time sirius was born he was
one of the few male heirs that remained
which meant his passing in the death
chamber on ninth level of the ministry
of magic marked the end of the black
family line
but even that wasn't really the end for
them
although the women of the family didn't
typically keep their last name after
marriage they married into dozens of
other pureblood families throughout
england in some way almost every weasley
potter lestrange lupin and malfoy could
find a connection to the blacks
today we're going to take a look at the
very first recorded ancestor in sirius's
line
and trace the history of the black
family from sirius's own namesake to the
final male heirs
if you take one look at the black family
tree you'll notice that the first
recorded generations lists five members
who lived around the early 19th century
although the film version of the black's
ancestry goes further back in time the
official canon which jk rowling has
referenced in her work begins here for
the remainder of this family tree i've
tried to stick as much as possible to jk
rowling's referenced version but at
times it was impossible to separate them
the first name on the list is sirius
black
after whom harry potter's godfather was
later named
this serious black was born in the year
1845
like everyone else in the black family
young sirius was a proudly pure blood
wizard
but unlike other members of his family
his life was cut tragically short
in the year 1853 the history books
revealed that sirius died at the age of
eight while it's tempting to point out
that many children died prematurely
before the rise of modern medicine
that was rarely the case in the
wizarding world thanks to their mastery
of potions and herbology wizards were
capable of healing almost any ailment
which means the cause of this serious
black's death might not have been an
accident
sirius was survived by three other
siblings all born after sirius
the first a boy named phineas nigella's
black was born in 1847
and became one of the most influential
members of the family to ever live
as most blacks would phineas attended
hogwarts and was of course placed into
house slytherin
phineas was also very vocal in carrying
on another family tradition his hatred
for muggles and mudbloods
after he graduated from hogwarts around
the year 1865
phineas married ursula flint together
they had five children
as a tribute to his older brother
phineas named his first child my son
sirius
and to carry on his own name he gave the
next boy his own as phineas black the
second
when we talk about the next generation
of the black family line we'll see that
even at this point the harsh rhetoric
around mudbloods would take its toll
ultimately causing phineas to reject
some of his own children
a bit later phineas and ursula birthed
cygnus belvina and arcturus when he
wasn't conceiving children vinius became
a professional teacher
passing on all that he had learned to
the next generation of wizards and
witches his talents eventually brought
him to hogwarts but it's hard to know
how effective he was as a teacher when
it comes to black's teaching style the
record books simply point out that he
hated his job and he hated the children
that didn't stop him from achieving
success though
as he eventually rose to the position of
headmaster together with ursula vinnie
has created the only recognized heirs
for the black family through their
marriage elodora one of phineus sisters
was also born in the years after the
eldest sirius as death unlike most of
her siblings elodora never found time to
create a family and perhaps due to her
modest contributions to the black family
tree we don't really know that much
about her
of the tales that survived elodora's
death none of them paint a particularly
flattering picture of the witch
one record claims that elodora created a
cruel black family tradition by
tormenting house elves
of her many ways of torturing the
creatures
sources claim that eledora instituted a
new rule
if a house elf was unable to carry a
tray of tea she would mount their head
on a wooden plaque and bolt them to the
wall the final member of this generation
iola hitchens is perhaps the most
exciting she was the fourth black
sibling of the age and she broke the
most important rule
she married a muggle or muggle-born
wizard the sources aren't very clear
much like her nephew who phineas the
elder would often debate
ayola didn't see the point in the black
family's obsession with a person's pure
blood status
until the time of her marriage aiola
most likely abided by the rules of her
family
she probably received a wizarding
education at hogwarts and only after
that decided to marry her partner bob
hitchens
since the pair were removed from the
black family tree
we don't know if they ever had any
children of their own but it's most
likely they did
whether or not any of their descendants
went on to rejoin the wizarding
community in the following decades was
never answered but it's not hard to
imagine that ayola's children or
grandchildren would have shown an
affinity for magic
and as long as her brother phineas
wasn't the headmaster at the time ayola
would have likely allowed her
descendants to enroll the next
generation of blacks was solely
comprised of the children of phineas and
ursula's marriage there were four sons
sirius black the second phineas black ii
cygnus black and arcturus black
and a single daughter belvina black
beginning with the eldest will find
sirius black ii
as we mentioned previously he was named
after his uncle who tragically died at
just eight years of age unlike his aunt
ayola's possible children
sirius ii was a pure blood wizard
born in 1877 sirius lived until the age
of 75
when he died of unknown reasons in the
year 1952
his contributions to the family line
came in the form of two sons and a
daughter whom he had with his wife
jesper gamp and his line actually became
the longest lived while his siblings
descendants either passed without heirs
or were married off into different
families sirius the second line produced
males to inherit the family name until
the
1970s with the birth of the final black
boys sirius iii and regulus
finnish the elders second son was named
after himself but phineas black ii born
in 1878 disappointed his father and
eventually got his name blasted off the
family tree
like his aunt mayola vinnies couldn't
understand why his family was so
obsessed with pureblood status
even though his father was the
headmaster of the very school he
attended phineas time at hogwarts likely
only made matters worse
another famously pro-muggleborn wizard
was enrolled at the very same time
albus dumbledore although there aren't
any records of massive student-led
movements against the pureblood ideology
of the time
it's not unlikely that phineas the
younger would have spent his days with
like-minded gryffindors instead of the
slytherins he probably lived with
phineas ii's younger brother arcturus
black was born over six years later in
1884
arcturus married another pureblood in
the british wizarding community
lysandra yaxley
although they weren't as prolific as
many of the other blacks the pair raised
three lovely daughters
caledora cedrella and carys
one just like her great aunt ayola fell
in love with someone the black family
looked down on
ignoring her father's wishes cedrella
went on to marry the man she loved
septimus weasley
it's through this bond that the weasley
family including all of arthur's
children
became distantly related to sirius black
iii
as women the records for arcturus's
children weren't kept on the family tree
but each married into high-profile
wizarding families while cedrella
married into the weasleys her elder
sister caledora married harfang
longbottom
possibly linking harry potter's
classmate neville to sirius black
the third sister carys married casper
crouch and was probably related to the
future death eater who shared the same
last name the next of phineus the
first's children was belvina born in
1886
as another daughter in the black family
tree she unfortunately was pushed to the
side of history
although there isn't much that we know
about her we do know that she got
married to a pureblood named herbert
burke together they had three children
but the history books stopped there the
final member of phineas the first
children was cygnus black
born in 1889 he was also lucky enough to
see his father serve as head master in
hogwarts
with his wife violetta bullstrode
sickness fathered four children
two sons and two daughters
cygnus life was fairly plain compared to
his brothers and sisters none of his
children committed a grave sin against
the family by marrying a muggle or
muggleborn however one of cygnus's
children was born without any magical
abilities a great shame for any
pureblood family cygnus went through
great efforts to hide this fact and even
blasted the name of the child off the
family tree when we move to the third
generation of the black family that's
officially tracked on their family tree
we'll find that only sirius the second's
children and his brother cygnus children
carry on the family name
as we mentioned earlier their sister
belvina's children weren't documented
and their brother arcturus only produced
daughters if we look at sirius the
second's children first we'll find that
his oldest arcturus black iii was born
in 1901 and was alive during sirius the
third's imprisonment in azkaban
in fact sirius black was one of
arcturus's two grandchildren
at some point after attending hogwarts
arcturus married a pureblood witch named
melania macmillan
their children lucretia and orion both
went on to marry purebloods as well
making their family proud
when his grandson sirius black talks
about arcturus he reveals that his
grandfather must have been pretty
wealthy as he was able to bribe the
ministry of magic for an award
although this might have been said in
jest it's still likely true
sirius ii's next child like chorus black
was born in 1904 and lived until 1965.
the reason for his fairly early death
wasn't given a reason
but considering she never married or
produced children the black family
historians weren't likely to devote too
much to her life like lycoris birth was
soon followed by another in 1906 with
the arrival of a second son
named regulus his name would eventually
be lent to sirius the third's brother
like his older sister regulus the first
never married and never had children at
a time when marriage was almost
compulsory it's strange to see that two
members of sirius ii's immediate family
didn't go on to raise any sons or
daughters of their own moving on to the
children of cygnus and violetta
will discover how they became relatives
to bellatrix lestrange and even
voldemort himself
sickness's eldest son was pollux black
he was born in 1912 and lived long
enough to see the wizarding world
condemn his descendant sirius black for
his supposed crimes his wife ermakrab
was important in bringing not just the
crabs but the lestranges tonks and
malfoy's into the family line as well
cygnus next child was a daughter named
cassiopeia black
records show she was born in 1915
just three years after her older brother
pollux and died in 1992
her skills in witchcraft and wizardry
were nothing noteworthy and
unfortunately she didn't contribute much
to the legacy of the black family
alongside her other siblings however she
lived long enough to see the black
family name dragged through the mud as
their youngest generation joined the
death eaters and failed to bring
voldemort to power not long after
cassiopeia's birth cygnus and his wife
violetta had another son marius you'll
notice that his name on the family tree
has been stricken out because
just like so many other members of his
family he betrayed the values of pure
bloods that the black so dearly
cherished but it wasn't entirely his
fault marius was born without an
affinity for magic
that meant he never attended hogwarts
got the chance to hear the sorting hat
filter him into house cytherin or even
wield a wand the shame of his condition
was so great that the black family
treated young marius as if he were a
muggle or half-blood
they didn't even list his wife or
children in the official genealogical
records despite the fact that his
descendants could have very well
possessed magical powers of their own
after marius's birth his parents were
cautious about having another child
but in the year 1920 they celebrated the
birth of their fourth a witch named
doria interestingly doria went on to
marry a distant relation of harry potter
a pure blood wizard known as charles
potter who must have died before harry's
own parents did as the dursleys were his
only known relatives at the time
through doria harry was not only related
to sirius black but also the malfoys
tonks crabs weasleys and just about
every other prominent wizarding family
in britain now as we move towards the
next generation you'll notice something
we're getting closer and closer to the
most famous member of the black family
sirius the third if we start with the
children of sirius black ii
will find that arcturus was seemingly
the first to marry
with his wife melania macmillan arcturus
raised two children
the first a daughter named lucretia was
born in 1925
after attending hogwarts and making her
parents proud as an accomplished witch
she went on to marry a prominent wizard
in the community
a young man known as ignatius pruitt
although lucretia and ignatius didn't
have any children of their own they were
deeply loved by their nieces and nephews
in fact ignatius seemed to have a
particularly deep relationship with
molly weasley who would later go on to
fight against another member of her
family bellatrix lestrange
lucretia had a younger brother about
four years later named orion his life
was relatively short even by the black
family standards born in 1929 and dead
by 1979
orion was remembered by his descendants
as a bitter deeply prejudiced old man
he was as tyrannical in his beliefs
about pure blood supremacy as any other
member of his family tree and that's
what drove a wedge between him and his
sons sirius black iii and regulus
besides being sirius's father orion's
other contribution to the black family
was in making the tapestry a bit more
convoluted since he married a family
member a second cousin named wolberger
wolberger was the daughter of pollock's
black and irma crab and one of the few
of her generation to have children
born in 1925 she outlived her husband by
only a few years
wolberger's younger brother alfred black
was another one of pollox's children but
he wasn't as well loved as his sister
he died in the late 70s and instead of
leaving his massive wealth to his
parents or his siblings he left most of
it to his nephew sirius
this strange posthumous gift angered his
relative so much that wolberger blasted
his name off of the tapestry
if you remember that type of punishment
was typically reserved for blood
traitors
after alfred pollock's and irma had a
third and final child sickness who they
named after pollux's father
through cygnus's children the black
family married into not only the tonks
and malfoy's but also produced an
illegitimate heir of voldemort
delfini
as we move on to the fifth and final
generation of the black family
the number of descendants has shrunk
quite a bit
in fact of the five blacks of this era
only two were male
and they died before they were able to
produce any heirs
ending the family name once and for all
the black family tradition of quickly
disowning their children as blood
traitors and ignoring the children that
their female descendants bore had
finally caught up with them if we turn
our attention to the suns that orion
black and his wife and cousin wolberger
produced will finally find the most
famous members of the family first in
1959 sirius was born he was the third
male in his family to bear the name but
rebelled against almost everything they
stood for
sirius was staunchly opposed to his
father's narrow view of the world
namely that only pureblood wizards
deserved respect and fair treatment one
of his biggest acts of rebellion was
when he allowed the sorting hat to
suggest gryffindor during the selection
process
for centuries the blacks had only
enrolled in slytherin and sirius was the
only one to defy that tradition
later as many of his cousins and
relatives joined voldemort's forces
sirius rejected the movement
ultimately through a carefully
orchestrated scheme black was framed for
horrendous crimes and imprisoned in
azkaban when he eventually escaped he
briefly reunited with his godson harry
potter before dying at the hands of his
own cousin bellatrix lestrange
unlike sirius orion's other son regulus
was initially seduced by the dark
wizards of his generation
for a brief time the younger black
brother joined the death eaters and
carried out their missions of propaganda
and violence
shortly after joining though regulus
decided that the death eaters were far
too dangerous and actively tried to
sabotage them in his final act regulus
tracked down one of voldemort's
horcruxes but failed to destroy it
instead the in fairy who surround the
lake with the horcrux was kept dragged
regulus into the cold waters
drowning him in the process when we move
on to cygnus black iii and his children
we'll find most of the families involved
in the final wizarding war that shook
hogwarts to its foundations in the late
90s
cygnus first child a daughter was the
evil witch bellatrix the strange after
graduating from hogwarts bellatrix
quickly joined the cult of voldemort and
became a powerful death eater in his
army during campaigns for voldemort
bellatrix used her powerful dueling
skills to kill many of voldemort's most
prominent opponents
even though she was related to most she
didn't hesitate in butchering them and
among the many she murdered sirius black
and nym fedora tonks stood highest on
the list
in the end bellatrix's end took a
surprising turn
when she was defeated and killed by
molly weasley another one of her distant
relations
although the black family tree wouldn't
typically keep track of a female black's
heirs
bellatrix's single child was of
particular note
her daughter named delfini wasn't
actually conceived with her husband
rodolfos the strange but instead with
lord voldemort himself eventually
delfini would challenge the wizarding
world in the very same way her father
had some time after bellatrix was born
her sister andromeda came into the world
when we look at the black family tree we
can easily see the familiar black
charred remains that surround her
picture
which means that she too was blasted off
of the tapestry
andromeda's crime was falling in love
with a muggle-born wizard named ted
tonks
although the family didn't recognize
them all their offspring andromeda's
marriage produced nymphadora lupin a
powerful aura and member of the order of
the phoenix in 1955 cygnus had a final
child another daughter this one was
named narcissa
and after attending hogwarts she married
lucius malfoy together they had a single
son draco and briefly brought the power
of the elder wand into the family
although andromeda bellatrix and
narcissa had children and grandchildren
of their own the black family ended with
the deaths of regulus and sirius as both
were the final male heirs and both were
childless
and perhaps that was for the best the
rise and fall of lord voldemort revealed
many flaws in the old way of thinking
a line of thought that the blacks seem
to value above all else their emphasis
on the importance of their name male
heirs and pure-blooded marriages was out
of place in the new world and even their
final death eater descendant draco
malfoy
raised his children in a much more
progressive fashion
promoting the inherent worth of all
beings not just those with pure blood
heritage
and that's it for this video if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you